we do have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two David P I got
an interesting voicemail about furries
yesterday take a listen to this hi David
I I don't know if you know this most
bizarre thing you hear this week I don't
suppose you've ever heard of the furry
Raiders if you don't know I'm sure you
don't there are these all right Nazi
Fareed I'm not getting that in the first
and them that have closed down like to
convention so farthing with a Rocky
Mountain for invention and caliper and I
just want to know like what your
thoughts are on those on those I'm sure
you I yeah so for people who don't know
furries are I know that I always use the
wrong terminology but they're people who
dress up as animals right there were
animal costumes I know that I think they
object to the concept of calling them
costumes and they object to the concept
of calling it dress up but basically
it's humans who dress like I'm an thoria
anthropomorphised animals I think
apparently it's not always a sexual
thing to yeah not always and then of
course you have the alt right and I
guess what this callers saying is that
there is a particular contingent of
alt-right furries and I've never heard
of that and I don't really care about it
but it sounds odd yeah not the most
bizarre thing all week not even the most
bizarre thing all day we did a story
today about how Republicans like Kim
jong-un more than LOC so that's the one
part I really disagree with which is
it's not even close to the strangest
thing I've heard on the bonus show today
we will talk about Donald Trump's desire
for a space force a space military we
will talk about the millionaire ballot
tax quite a millionaire tax ballot
question here in Massachusetts and why
is Domino's Pizza purveyor of truly bad
pizza now filling potholes I have a few
guesses and I'll give you the
explanation on the bonus show become a
member at join Pakman
calm or become a patron two great ways
to access the bonus show